so we're hearing more about the
lockdown's bad effects on children's
mental states but that's only half the
equation sure they missed out on team
sports playgrounds and field trips my
rooftop petting zoo was a disaster
all the goats jumped
but what did the kids replace this with
well i'll give you a hint it wasn't
twister it's something made in china
not cheap lawn furniture or covet itself
i'm talking tick-tock which is aptly
named for a time bomb and what do you
get from tip top tick tock you get
teachers like this
hey if your parents don't love and
accept you for who you are this
christmas
i'm your parents now i'm proud of you
drink some water i love you
with parents like that who needs woody
allen
that person has since resigned
resign he resigned to the fact that he's
back crazy anyway he's probably already
got a job at disney he'll be vp in
charge of grooming i mean recruitment
maybe they dress like mice so witnesses
don't have a description
but that's not the only nutcase on
tick-tock the app is a non-stop faucet
of unstable creeps like an nyc subway
but with a direct line into your kid's
room next stop brainwash boulevard take
a look
man y'all thought me teaching the
children about me being polly was crazy
but not only that but they also know
that i'm gender fluid when babies are
born the doctor looks at them and they
make a guess about whether the baby is a
boy or a girl based on what they look
like and most of the time that guess is
100 correct there are no issues
whatsoever
but sometimes the doctor is wrong i
teach my elementary school students
about gender identity some people are
girls some are boys some are both some
are neither uh why do they all have
crazy eyes
that should tell you something so much
like adult progressives kids don't have
fully formed brains and this is what
they see every day
god knows if i got that sort of input
when i was young who knows how i would
have ended up today
but the destructive influence social
media has on kids has gotten so bad that
even people on the other side of things
see that it's bad
but maybe kids eating tide pods it
should have been a tip off the la times
published a story about transgender
clinical psychologist erica anderson
who's helped hundreds of teens aiming to
transition from one gender to another in
the piece she wonders whether this surge
in teens announcing their trans is egged
on by social media and that so-called
experts are failing to evaluate these
kids properly
and no doctors can't use the i'm not a
biologist excuse instead they recommend
hormones or surgeries now that might be
fine for caitlyn jenner but not for kids
it's not that we're anti-trans we're
just pro-age appropriateness and it's a
concern why the interest in the genders
of strangers kids all of a sudden
now anderson is at the forefront of
transgender care and even she says this
doesn't make sense she's seen more than
a doubling of new patients from 2019 to
2021. she notes the pattern kids are in
quarantine with lots of free time to
spend on social media quote online a
stream of transgender influencers and
activists told teens that if they felt
uncomfortable with their bodies or
didn't fit in story of my life maybe
they were trans
some coached kids on how to bind their
breasts how to change their name and
pronouns at school how to push their
parents for testosterone so that's from
a trans expert who is trans she
concludes any social influence in
formation of gender identity flies in
the face of reality
so step back and look at what's
happening you have disney and it's
supportive media mocking and shaming
parents for wanting what's best for
their young kids you have teachers
pushing curriculum that encourages kids
to ask for hormone blockers to suppress
their puberty maybe they want to delay
adulthood to keep indoctrinating them
you have anyone who dare mention
biological sex in public be deemed
transphobic somehow mother became
offensive without being followed by the
f word
you have criminals changing gender to
get into women's prisons which is
ridiculous just put on a wig and hide in
one of the laundry carts like i do
so where is all this coming from it's
very sudden you know i get the adults
people like us assistant secretary for
health rachel levine transitioned from
male to female
in her 50s
clearly she thought a lot about it so
did caitlyn jenner we're not talking
about that we're talking about kids and
what feels like a social phenomenon and
not a biological one a gender version of
tide pods you know i'm doing it why
aren't you
the longer we deny this the more kids
will fall under the spell of influencers
than the knives of doctors who forgot
the hippocratic oath
kids are confused they're vulnerable
they're scared desperate to belong
desperate to feel special they still
have to be told not to put their fingers
in outlets
they're literally made for grooming and
who's doing it maybe check your kid's
computer search history the call is
coming from inside the house
while mom and dad are at work vulnerable
and naturally confused kids go on tick
tock where attentive persuasion awaits
it's most effective on vulnerable kids
desperate to fit in somewhere i bet
disney's mad they didn't think of it
first
look you don't have to listen to me
about this i got no kids last time i
checked i'm a straight white male i used
a full-length mirror
but listen listen to the trans clinical
psychologist who ironically has the
stones few others have and when she's
sounding the alarm it's like keith
richards telling you you have a drug
problem
ignore it at your own peril
let's welcome tonight's guest
she placed fourth in the miss usa
pageant and the other three have since
met an untimely demise
host of fox news at night and author of
the new book the mothers and daughters
of the bible speak
shannon breen
when he approaches the bench judges ask
how much you bench former acting
attorney general matt whitaker
her taxes are like her hair lots of
extensions fox news contributor cat tim
and finally he needs binoculars to see
his toes my massive sidekick
and the nwa world television champion
it's because he's stalled champion tyrus
shannon congrats on the new book it gave
me an idea i'm writing a religious book
i can't wait scallywags of the bible yes
it's scallywags of the bible that was
nick no it's going to be called my
religious book okay
[Music]
you could do that you have a lot of
thoughts i know i know you have an index
and i noticed that god has like 300
entries and there's not a single one for
gut felt well
duly noted yes yes
i don't think god is happy about that
because i'm one of his children yes you
are you have no children and yet i'm
forcing you to ponder this interesting
issue this this kind of like thing where
the everybody was worried about their
kids not being outside and they forgot
to worry about what's inside yeah
exactly yeah my mom was a teacher for 40
plus years and so i cannot imagine
any of these conversations or
discussions that were going on in his
classroom none of this i think was
happening with marie but what i found so
interesting is a couple days ago there
was a piece and opinion piece in the
washington post by someone who did
transition from male to female at the
age of 19 and i thought the writer was
so interesting because no one's going to
know the experience better than them and
they said i crowded everybody out of my
life who would have questioned or
hesitated or said let's think about this
i only wanted 100 approval and now i've
made decisions i can't take back at such
a young age and i do have regrets would
i eventually transition maybe as an
adult with a little bit more experience
but i don't think it was healthy for me
to have all the power to do this as a
teenager kids kids make lousy decisions
matt i'm sure you made a ton of them
growing up a few here yeah i think i
heard shannon say a bad word she said
scallywag yes which i don't yes i was
offended yeah
hr is calling me that yeah i don't know
i don't think that's the swear word i've
ever heard
yeah it's exactly trash mouth yes you
have kids matt i do are they older
younger the youngest is 18. okay so
they're they're free to make up their
own minds but but what i see in through
their eyes is that social media is a
mirror and it feeds them what they're
interested in and what they linger on
they get more of and that's what's
really dangerous because if someone is
just
um
you know spends too much time looking at
these transitioning videos also they're
getting a steady diet of those types of
things and that's what's really
insidious about the whole
social media world it could be anything
it could be anything from anorexia or or
uh you know bad taste in music
yeah
not you i'm kidding but you know um i do
think tyrus i do think i want to go to
tyrus because you have you have kids and
this is something that yes the state of
the louisiana says i have four yes
you got a couple things you gotta admit
the tran the the the the psychologist
that the trans like has a lot of guts to
come out and say this uh after seeing
she said she saw
so many startled parents that were
showing up going like my kid just
announced he's trans and they don't know
what to do what it means
you know when i was a child i told my
mother i was gonna be the incredible
hulk
um but that did come true
in a way it did you're not green no well
you are green look at your tattoos right
right but it took time yeah it did take
coffee so he's transitioning to the hole
right now he's a good hulk
so
you brought it up no i'm just putting it
out there yeah that's what i identify as
so okay
okay
so
so
we have rules in this in this country
like you can't there's a reason why kids
can't come home from
second grade and crack a beer open right
man dad my day was let me tell you about
this that because you know they don't
drink alcohol because their minds are
developing right so when you say you got
to be 18 right you have 18 to vote you
have 18 to smoke we have rules in place
not to be mean because we're protecting
the youth until they can make big
decisions that's exterior things so of
course you're going to want your
children to grow and make a decision
when their mind is ready to make
decisions the problem is we have leading
experts on nothing and all we have now
on social media is projection
it's my world it's the way i see things
and you all have to see things like me
and we have thousands of geniuses on
there with nothing to back it up except
they like to film themselves a foot from
their face
that is the criteria yeah and you can
make everything there's people there is
there is 400 pound five foot
fitness trainers telling you if your
doctor asks you your weight tell him to
go to hell right because he shouldn't
ask you your weight because you should
be happy
being as fat as you want to be that
positive so yeah so why wouldn't you
then embrace being a deuce in a quarter
yeah when you're five five you know what
i'm saying it doesn't make any sense
because they have no
business pushing their beliefs and their
stuff on people yeah and when someone
else does it to them yeah when someone
says that i don't agree with your
lifestyle and in my household for
example like i'm a science guy but yeah
my kids might want to be in religion i
don't push my stuff on them right i let
them grow and figure it out and do the
same thing with their sexuality or any
other thing unless it was detrimental to
their health then i would step in yeah
and that's the problem is that no one's
drawing lines in the sand saying listen
you can preach your stuff but
keep it out of my household yeah cat if
i imagine if tick-tock was around when
you were a child what would have
happened to you because right now i mean
you're okay yeah you're on edge i was a
i was a remarkably androgynous child
both in terms of behavior and appearance
who did she look like remember she
looked like this the second baseman from
bad news bear yes yes and now you're a
little one with the mouth
mouth like her yes and now it kind of
depends how many hair extensions i'm
wearing
i don't really have like a womanly shape
but honestly yeah back then
no i
i i told my mom at one point that i
wanted a penis because i wanted to be
able to pee outside easier because i
also liked peeing outside because again
like totally androgynous
i am so glad nobody gave me one
like this transgender psychologist is
saying like hey like i'm transgender i
help kids transition but maybe like just
wait yeah like make sure
like that's something they tell people
when they're gonna like buy a house
right i feel like getting new genitals
is even more life-changing than that it
is trust me maybe kids
once you get on the property ladder
you'll understand yeah i don't own any
property
[Laughter]
i'm sorry no we can't all be as rich as
you you know you know um what the point
you're making is we're not anti-trans
it's about age appropriateness yeah and
it's like
that's getting lost in this debate
especially when when when disney got
involved and it was about a a parental
rights bill and then all those you are
anti-gay you're anti-la you're no no
parents are just saying i would be a
dude instead of a woman with a very
dude-like vibe yes but you can be
anti-you yes you don't you know what i'm
saying i don't like you and your choices
and how you present yourself and how you
pee standing up or sitting down is
irrelevant right i don't like you yes
that's what they're trying to stop
exactly and i want to be able to not
like anybody i don't like i do it all
the time you do i think i don't think he
likes me is there anyone
i like i think greg sits to pee i'm just
saying
well because he has him from yeah
because
because he's well you know it's tough
when you got to lean up you know
it's probably easier he has those little
party stairs in there
i'm going to go to tick tock plus how
can you drink wine and tweet at the same
time obviously you got to sit down all
right hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else